i'm so happy to be here well i will say
you are bringing the color with that
insanely beautiful bright marigold
jacket
thank you this is where my artistic
expression starts and stops i can do the
whole outfit but home i need help and i
moved into this new apartment and i
started with the kitchen and then the
kids bedrooms and then i left my bedroom
pretty bland and i got stuck and i just
stopped there do you mean that you
pulled the typical mom thing where you
took care of everyone else and then left
yourself high and dry everyone else
exactly i i mean between work uh the
kids
sometimes my husband i try to do it all
and then
you're too busy too busy i travel the
work i do i travel the country some
parts of the world you know i do a lot
of volunteering tell everybody what you
do because i'm really in love with your
story well i do um really economic
justice is what i do my mission is to
close the racial and gender wealth gap
and hi and hopefully overturn and
eradicate poverty
so i've worked um hurt yes please yes
yes yes
so i've i've worked with hurricane
katrina victims hurricane sandy victims
helping them find money to rebuild their
homes and go back home
um and i love the work that i do but
sometimes i leave some parts of myself
not taken care of well you are just such
an amazing person and you deserve
someone to take care of you the way you
take care of everyone else thank you
thank you so i got involved oh
i did i can't i i couldn't help myself
um
i
i have a little message um from your
family actually that i'd like you to
watch right now go ahead
surprise mom
we are working with team drew to create
a bedroom just for you our queen you're
such a good mom thank you for all you've
done for this family you're amazing we
love you
[Applause]
oh my goodness so cute they've got you
the way you've got them thank you you've
inspired them and set the tone right and
you are so deserving of this so we
wanted to transform your bedroom we want
to tackle that room and we want to put
some color into it get rid of the beige
kind of go for it let's go for it all
right
everything that you're about to see in
this room um i personally picked i
worked with the design team here at the
show
every single thing is going home with
you so everything in this room is yours
and we all
put a lot of love into this
are you ready to see it i'm ready oh my
gosh
all right let's reveal i'm so nervous
now
[Applause]
oh it's gorgeous
so
what i started with is this is actually
a flower home wallpaper i designed this
with
my design partners but i didn't want to
do the whole room in it so then i picked
up the blue ground and dragged that
through the walls i went with more wood
tones
because i just thought how can we bring
nature in so even
things that are made from wood actually
give you that sense of the outdoors i
went with a woven leather chair
because again i liked sort of the blue
and brown tones was what i was really
inspired by i also brought these natural
lamps in i kept thinking texture
woven we did the rug that sort of had
more of like a 3d pop so that it wasn't
flat i wanted you to have a big mirror
so you could look at your fabulous
outfit
and then this is our favorite edition
now these are photographs actually
of the communities that you've helped
and we added this gallery wall of
pictures beautiful that is new york city
the jersey shore new orleans
and that is in honor of the work that
you do
in an artistic way but also to remind
you of the incredible accomplishments
you do for everybody else
and to stay inspired to be the person
that you are
thank you so much this is so wonderful
it is perfect and you know i have blue
in one room in the living room so all of
this is amazing and this when i saw
these photos
my heart just dropped i love it that was
so this is so perfect i thank you so
much it was so perfect i'm so relieved
so perfect you like it
do you think you and your husband will
be happy i we we i'm excited i know
he'll be excited he said whatever you
say so i love it we need i've been
wanting this wallpaper again one of my
friends they sent it and i'm like where
do you buy it where do you start i don't
i don't even know where to begin so
you've done it already and i love navy
and the earth tones it's just beautiful
so i feel like this is also going to
bring the rest of the house together
it's beautiful
i'm so excited
i love it one minute i'm like i'm so
confident as a designer and now i'm like
it's
thank
perfect
so much
[Music]